oh hi wie findet ihr meinen neuen louis
welten tasche heute soll aber die zweite
neue louis bacon tasche gehen meine
lieben freunde denn ihr seht es bereits
im kalender heute ist dienstag von einer
herzlich willkommen
starten wir wieder mit dem besten tik
tok der woche
[Musik]
ja wenn du mir noch nicht auf tik tok
oder instagram folgt dann könnte ich
auch nicht empfehlen
sunshine wieder mitfahren mitmachen
anschließend hobby
perfekt ich habe den dienstag als
vermisst
es war eine minute ist vergangen
hey was mache ich meine schwester an
[Musik]
manchmal träume ich davon wie ich meinen
youtube-kanal mich gab corolla virus hat
mich erwischt
wollte ich eigentlich alle
waschen leicht auf gar keinen fall
niemals eure texte videos hier ist
niemand die wir angehen ich zum beispiel
jetzt ein video hochgeladen zwei videos
waren dass ich scheiße wenn ich
weggegangen nächsten morgen wieder
aufgewacht und dann 5
mein körper
gerade kurz davor in die luft zu fliegen
als 20 werden nach und von vorne denkt
man oh mein gott der ist richtig krass
bei mir wird das ganze so aussehen also
von hinten denkt man sich wo ist das
laub und der seite denkt man sich ersten
lauf aber dann von vorne denkt man sich
an gott ist das leicht durch deutschland
macht hat sie sich gerade ernsthaft
davor erschrocken dass sie einen filter
aktiviert hatte
wo bin ich hier gelandet
mg wie macht einen angeht sollte man
meinen abend geht sehen
ok es eigentlich ein ferrari hallo
das ist meine mutter bei aldi netto hat
aldi netto
[Musik]
warum
bekomme ich so etwas auf meiner homepage
angezeigt
ich darf mich ich muss
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
war das erste tor was wir heute wirklich
leicht schmunzler locken konnte zwei
arten von star wars fans der normale gab
es da wo sie cool weil das war ja mal
und der star wars sucht die ja beide
lieben freunde wer kennt nicht die jedis
in einem star wars kampf sagen natürlich
immer wenn sie mit ihrem licht schweren
kämpfen hey ich bin pizza sohn so
unterhaltsam dass dem typen bitte mal
liebe grüße da machen wir nun allerdings
mit einem video weiter wo wir ein
ähnliches tik tok schon in der letzten
episode tik tok tuesday hatten und zwar
ging es dabei darum dass man das tik tok
abspielen sollte wenn man keinen bock
mehr auf sein date hat und dann hat der
typ sein unterhaltung vorgetäuscht jetzt
haben wir allerdings einen tick tock
dass man abspielen soll wenn man in
gefahr ist also genau zuhören ja und ich
fahre das müsse nicht mehr lang sein
wir sehen dich auch schon da bist du ja
wesentlich da natürlich
ja
da hoffe ich dass sich nie in gefahr
sein werde
er will jetzt einfach probiert das heute
ja
[Musik]
uns so schnell sind wir wieder auf dem
boden der tatsachen angekommen
war das eine gummi schlange
richtige schlange müsste das nicht
normalerweise anders gesagt
alba dreistein hier am start oder lachen
kann dann die 3 hallo lara 2 habe ich
heute zeit ja habe ich an den banden zu
gegen 32 verbessern
g2 auch geht hier auch noch markiert
wird auch mannschaft zog er geht bei dir
dabei mir aber junge berlin ganz egal
wie du willst ganz egal wer mir ist aber
auch egal
mama sagt du das
immer so und heutzutage klärt man sowas
über 70.000 sprachnachrichten bot sich
ein bisschen traurig bin dass meine
worte die ich jetzt so oft gesagt habe
auch in der gleichen weise scheinbar
überhaupt nicht respektiert werden und
ich finde das könnte man tun wahrheit
muss ganz schnell los bruder ab ich kann
nicht
20 euro
wurde es gerade anlass genommen die
leute das geht dann alles soll ich
profilbilder bewerten auf tik tok wenn
ja dann schreibt mir und wenn ihr für
ein scheitern schreibt schreibt nein und
wenn ihr für jahr steigend schreibt ja
ich würde mich sehr freuen
ok
schauen wir uns mal an wie er jetzt die
profilbilder bewertet ich bewerte ich
als profilbilder und das erste bild ist
hier in der brille auf jedenfalls
ausgiebig klar kraft nie zehn von eins
bis zehn gewicht dem netz sehen herrlich
7 gegeben
da das nächste aus gta auf jeden fall
sieht auch mega ausgiebig macht ja da
schließe ich mich dir an wer lieber
pizza sohn würde ich auch noch abgeben
sieht cool aus mit dem spleen logo auch
und so das ist das dritte dafür gebe ich
auf jeden fall
das ist ein sehr schönes bild und ja
auch für die stars ja dass jetzt das
nächste bild da gebe ich auf jeden fall
ist ein sehr schönes bild ich hoffe du
siehst dass welche zahl gibt sie ihm
jetzt aber okay machen war mit dem
letzten foto jetzt auch weiter dann auf
jeden fall noch ein bild dafür gebe ich
eine klare 10 für das bild das ist genau
die richtige einstellung genau die
richtige einstellung
wenn euch das gefallen hat dann gibt mir
planeggs follower auf jeden fall unter
kommentiert fleißig danke seit dem
besten bild gebe ich auch eine zehn ganz
klar und kommentiert alle fleißig seid
die besten er wirklich bitter so nicht
finden konnten so unterhaltsam sehr groß
haben wir mal wieder einen neuen
tiefpunkt erreicht allerdings würde ich
sagen kommen jetzt auch schon zum
letzten tick tock für die heutige wieso
die tik tok tuesday und zwar ist es ein
video in dem ein mädchen mit einer
fliege tic tac toe spielt fragt mich und
schaut einfach
käser yours
[Musik]
okay okay
an der stelle ist das wollte ich mir
jetzt als operetten meine lieben freunde
wenn euch die heutige wieso die tik tok
user immer wieder gefallen hat und zeigt
mir gerne da der bewertung schaffen wir
40.000 like mega mega heiß und wenn ihr
mir noch nicht auf tik tok folgt oder
auf instagram hat sich genauso dann hier
laser luca schaut gern vorbei ich mache
den beschützten content in ganz
deutschland jetzt befindet ist
allerdings auch schon im auto meine
lieben freunde wenn sie noch kein
abonnent von meinem kanal sei dann
klickt hier oben gerne auf den zwei
lieder auf deiner meldet die zahl der
luchse und verpasst keine videos mehr
und es ist kostenlos und s-klasse und
hier ist ein anderes video verlinkt wenn
ihr wenn ihr nichts
[Musik]